let's now think about different ways to
represent a mixed number and let's say
that our mixed number is two
and
two and one eighth
two and one eight actually let's make a
little bit more interesting let's make
it two
and 1 4
2 and 1 4. so let's first think about
the whole number part the 2
well the 2 is going to be
the 2 is literally 2 wholes you could
literally view that if you want right
here we've drawn each hole we've we've
cut it up into sections of eight so it
literally is eight eighths so it's
so let me just do it like this so the
two is this whole region right over here
that's one
so this right over here is one
and then this right over here is two
two holes
so let me paint that in
so that is two holes
and then i have one fourth so this last
piece this last hole is divided into
eight sections so let me divide it into
fourths first
so
that's one-fourth two-fourths
and three-fourths
so we want one of those four to be
filled in
one of those four
in orange so one of those four to be
filled in so just like that you might
notice that i filled in two of the
eights and that's because 1 4 and 2 8 is
the same thing so there i've represented
this mixed number 2 and 1 4. let's see
how we can decompose this so let's get
our grids back
so how else could we do it and i'm just
going to throw a bunch of fractions up
there and see what i get
see what i get so what i the first thing
i'm going to throw out is
one-half
so let's say that i want to throw out
so how would i represent one-half here
well if i take one of these holes and i
put it into two sections right over here
a half would be this section right over
there so let me color that in
so we have a half
so i'm first going to add
a half
which is the same thing as four eights
and you see that i just filled in four
out of the eight sections which is
exactly half of this of this first hole
so we're making some progress
now let's throw in
now let's throw in i don't know let's
turn three
eights so what would three eighths look
like
well three eighths that's going to be
these are literally each of these boxes
are literally an eighth and i could fill
it in however i want but let me just put
this is one
two
and three
and then let's fill in
let's fill in plus
i don't know plus another
8 8
8 8. now what's 8 8 well 8 8 is a whole
and i'll do that over here i still
haven't filled this one in yet but i'll
fill in this one right over here
so let's do that so 8 8.
so that's 1 8
7 8 and 8 8 and it's a hole so i have a
whole hole here so that's 8 8. i still i
want to make this one a whole because i
want to get to two so let me put in a 1
8 there
so plus 1 8
so plus
1 8
well that's going to be this one right
over here so that's my 1 8
and then let's add another
i don't know let's add another 2 8
plus
another 2 8
2 8.
well this is an eighths right over here
so 2 8 is going to be two of these
and notice you see
that the 2 8 is the same thing as 1 4.
if you took each of these if you took
this one-fourth and
split it into two so you have two two
times as many pieces it becomes two
eighths and you see that if one times
two is two
four times two is eight so that
one-fourth is the same thing as
two-eighths you see the eight-eighths is
the same thing as the whole and you see
you can make another hole out of one
half
plus 3 8 plus 1 8 and they they add up
to a whole and just to make sense of why
that worked this is one half could be
written
one half is the same thing as 4 8
because you see that we filled in the 4
then you have 3 8
and then you have 1 8
1 8 and if you add all of these together
4 8 plus 3 8 plus 1 8 you will get you
are going to get in terms of eighths
4 8 plus 3 8 plus 1 8 is going to be 8 8
4 plus 3 plus 1 is 8. so you get 8 8
which is this entire hole so hopefully
that helps give you a visual
understanding of what we're doing when
we're adding and decomposing these
fractions a little bit more